if you were watching the show yesterday
you know that I I started the show by
kind of bragging a little bit about my
globe here would end for good reason
because a globe when you add a globe
into the situation it immediately makes
everything classier and more
professional and more intelligent so
even though I don't have a real studio
or a real set I do have the globe and
the point that I made was well yeah the
other guys at The Daily wire they've got
a studio they've got a set they don't
have a globe though do they
so who really has the most professional
show with the daily wire that that was
that was my argument anyway but after
the show a lot of people informed me
that actually Clavin does have a globe
on his set I never noticed it before but
I went back and I and I watched and yeah
there is kind of off in the corner it's
not displayed prominently like my globe
but he does have a globe so this is what
I'm gonna do I didn't want to have to do
this but I'm going to add a second globe
and so now I have the most globes both
in terms of globe quantity and also
total global all um-- and if it's really
necessary for me to pull out the big
guns and I and I'm kind of hesitant here
because I well I don't mean the show off
but if I really need to
I also have this and I could do the
entire show with this globe as well and
what would look more professional or
more intelligent than that okay but I
won't
I won't yet unless it's really necessary
now these globes are kind of relevant to
what I want to talk about and before I
get into the real subject in all
seriousness I should add a little bit of
a parental disclaimer parental advisory
if you're watching this or listening to
this and you have little kids around you
may want to pause it and come back to it
because we're gonna talk about some
things that are a bit graphic and
upsetting but also necessary in order
for me to make the point that I want to
make so ben shapiro wrote a piece
yesterday for the daily wire taking note
of a report which was published in
science magazine and the report yet
again reveals the the unbelievable scale
of
human sacrifice and barbarity among the
ancient Aztecs and Shapiro was using
this to make the point that we tend to
romanticize foreign cultures especially
Native American cultures and in the
process when we romanticizing them we
kind of tend to ignore just the sheer
savagery that was and in some cases
still is so common in certain cultures
what Shapiro is really the point he was
really making is that this kind of
cultural equivalency that we do where we
say well all cultures are equal you
can't judge any cultures no culture is
better than any other culture that is
clearly not the case as evidenced by the
human sacrifices among lasting the
Spanish culture the Spanish who
conquered the Aztecs their culture in
their civilization was clearly better
than the Aztec culture and this is me
talking now not been the Spanish culture
was superior in every way
now when I say superior that is not a
racial designation it's not it's got
nothing to do with race its superior
because it was superior in terms of its
scientific achievements its artistic
achievements its even its philosophical
and political achievements yeah the
Aztecs had big big cities and they had
they had a big temples that they built
they even had some artwork although
their art was largely hideous and
grotesque and terrifying but they had
all that stuff but they had not advanced
anywhere near as far as the European
said but when I say that the Spanish
civilization was a superior civilization
I mean primarily morally it was a
morally superior civilization the
Spanish weren't perfect by any means and
they did practice some they practice
slavery but then again every single
civilization in the world in 16th
century practiced slavery so that's not
much of a surprise none of that compares
to the Aztecs though the Aztecs
would build these great temples where
ritual human sacrifices would occur with
the brutality and in a volume that is
just incomprehensible some historians
estimate that the Aztecs sacrificed up
to 50,000 human beings a year keep in
mind there were only about four or five
million people living in Aztec territory
so that means that they would have
sacrificed about 1% of their total
population on an annual basis that is an
astronomical figure and when I say
sacrifice we should understand what that
means what it means is that they would
they would they would take the offering
up to the top of the pyramid they would
put him down on a slab they would plunge
in the priests would plunge a knife into
the chest of the person and cut a big
hole reach his hand then and while the
person is still alive rip out his
beating heart and then they would cut
off his head and his limbs his torso
would be rolled down the steps and then
his limbs would often time be
ritualistically consumed by the other
Aztec priests there was a period of
about four days when the Aztecs were
coordinating a new temple that they had
just built where they carried out this
process with 80,000 people in four days
they sacrificed 80,000 people in four
days and they would furnish themselves
with sacrifices mainly by conquering and
subjugating neighboring tribes so when
you hear about how the Europeans showed
up and they stole land and they did all
this well the Aztecs like many other
Indian civilizations the land that they
possess they had themselves stolen it
and when the Aztecs stole your land they
didn't just steal your land they would
then start taking your people and
bringing them to the top of a temple and
ripping out their hearts that's what the
Aztecs would do if you in fact if you're
curious curious about how the and that's
how
Aztecs treated their own people and
other Indians if you're curious about
how the Aztecs treated the Spanish here
is a I just briefly read a passage this
is a book called Cortez about the clash
of civilizations between the Spanish and
the Aztecs by Richard Lee Marx is a
great book I recommend reading it and
it's it's non bias it's very objective
book but here's just a quick passage so
this is later on in the book after this
after the fighting had begun between the
Spanish and the Aztecs up until this
point the Spanish had been relatively
merciful toward the Aztecs but then some
Spanish were caught by the Aztecs they
were prisoners of war and while the
other Spanish soldiers stood off at a
far distance a few miles away watching
this this this is what happened to the
to this Spanish prisoners they were all
taken they were stripped naked they were
brought to the pyramid to the to the
temple they were brought up the steps
they were forced to dance naked in front
of the in front of the demonic idols of
the Aztecs and then here's what happened
after an hour
this is an hour of dancing of these of
these prisoners dancing naked after an
hour
a high priest signaled and the dancing
was terminated though the beating of the
drum and the jingling of the bells and
tambourines continued Aztec priests
rushed forward and took back from the
dancers their headdresses and plumes
then the first victim was pulled to the
sacrifice stone thrown down on his back
and held spread-eagle the high priest
came forward held above his head the
Flint knife and drove it into the
victims chest he then cut across the
ribs and plunging his hand into the
chest cavity tore loose the beating
heart the priest held aloft the
Spaniards heart with which with its few
final spasms gush blood that fell on the
priests face while a din of shrieking
rose from the other people that the
other Indians were watching this the
other priests
took the heart into the temple placed it
before the idols while others
systematically
cut off the victims head arms and legs
and disdainfully rolled the split open
torso to the top of the steps with a few
kicks sent it downward and then this was
repeated for all the victims now as I
said up to that point the asked the
Spanish had been relatively merciful
towards the Aztecs but now they're
watching this take place and this again
this is just barbarity and savagery that
the Europeans had never encountered
before they couldn't even conceive of it
and they're watching this happening
their policy of being relatively
merciful
well that was out the window and I think
understandably so they realized that
okay if we're gonna beat these people
we're gonna have to be pretty brutal
about it now the significance of this
report in science magazine which which
cites new archeological evidence is that
it corroborates the testimony from the
Spanish themselves the Spanish told
stories of finding these temples stacked
with human skulls like thousands of
human skulls that have been stacked and
were being displayed like trophies and
nobody no one's ever doubted that these
sacrifices took place that's a matter of
historical record but some for a long
time have tried to argue that the
Spanish exaggerated the scale of it well
we now have the remains of these giant
skull racks and so it's pretty clear
that that the Spanish did not exaggerate
I think we can glean two important
things from all this number one it's you
know what been argued is correct that
not all cultures are equal the Aztecs
were clearly a more brutal more savage
more frankly evil culture
and if it was a white civilization doing
this if it was if it was a white
civilization enslaving thousands of
people and ripping their hearts out and
eating them everybody would agree that
that that that that's a country needs to
that needs to be invaded and the ruling
forces need to be toppled aggressively
but in this case we kind of see it as
some kind of travesty
that this brutal regime was toppled just
because of the racial dynamics at play
and by the way when Cortez launched his
final siege of the capital city where
what is now Mexico City it's true that
ultimately the entire city was destroyed
and almost every inhabitant was
slaughtered but most of the wholesale
slaughter did not happen on the part of
the Spanish it was on the part of the
Indian allies of the Spanish who had
been oppressed for years by the Aztecs
and so they were they wanted vengeance
and so the other Indians went into the
you know they they they went in with the
Spanish and they started pulling men
women and children out of their homes
and just slaughtering them in the
streets
but here's the second thing that we can
glean from all this
it's okay for us in the West to admire
and honor the great men who built our
civilization men like Cortez for
instance
they were flawed you know they certainly
were flawed and Europeans were guilty of
atrocities of their own but nobody tells
Native Americans that they can't be
proud of their heritage nobody tells
them that even though in the case of the
Aztecs and many other Indian
civilizations they they were guilty of
just barbaric atrocities
but no one tells Native Americans who
can't be you can't be proud of your past
and you can't have your own heroes that
you look
by the way the Mayans also practiced
human sacrifice and in fact
archaeologists recently uncovered in
Mayan territory a mass grave of toddlers
who had been sacrificed
the Incas down in South America around
the same time they were also avid human
sacrifices they were they would take
children fatten them up lead them to the
top of a mountain and then strangle them
to death or leave them there to die of
exposure in the cult and the Mayans
Incas Aztecs these were the three major
Indian civilizations throughout Central
and South America all of them were
unspeakably brutal yet we don't indict
them for it and we don't say that those
who have that heritage shouldn't be
proud of it
but this is how it goes every
non-western non-white country is allowed
to celebrate its history allowed to
celebrate its heritage they're allowed
to celebrate the great men and women who
helped build their civilizations even if
those men and women are guilty of
terrible things and even if they they
also stole land and enslaved and did all
those things I mean you could go to
Mongolia and find stat monuments to
Genghis Khan Genghis Khan raped half the
women women in Asia
I mean Genghis Khan just went throughout
Asia enslaving conquering and raping
that was his entire career yet they
build monuments to him and nobody would
ever even dream of telling a Mongolian
that you shouldn't look up the Genghis
Khan
even though Genghis Khan was a was a
horrible person yet in the West
we're supposed to hold our heroes and
our pioneers to this impossibly high
standard and if they committed any crime
if they were guilty of any sin even if
it was a sin utterly common to their
time and shared by almost everyone of
all races like slavery well in that case
we're supposed to tear down their
monuments and spit on their graves
that's only in the West we don't expect
anyone else to do that it's only in our
civilization in our culture that we're
required to do that
take Columbus as another example
Columbus
you know our treatment of Columbus in
modern times is just disgraceful and
utterly stupid Columbus was a great man
a great great man who achieves something
spectacular achieve something
earth-shattering world-changing he
achieved something far more significant
than anything you will ever in your life
achieve or me will never even come close
to doing what Columbus did and yet now
we treat him with with like contempt
and we focus oh no this is the bad thing
that he did look at these bad things
dumbest of all people will go you know
that this is this this is the stupidest
thing when people say say well what
Columbus didn't even mean to discover
America and he never set foot on North
America and the Vikings got there first
ha ha
what an idiot Columbus was he didn't
even mean to yeah those are nice little
tidbits of information that you acquired
from Facebook memes but they're not
relevant to anything
of course Columbus didn't mean to
discover America nobody knew that
America existed how could they no one
knew it was there no one had seen it and
if that's if the Vikings did stumble
upon Newfoundland at some point
centuries prior they didn't establish a
lasting colony they didn't continue
their exploration they didn't understand
the significance of their discovery or
leave clear records of it so as far as
Europe knew in 1492 the world consisted
of one giant landmass and a huge ocean
in between you know separating one side
from the other that's as far as anyone
knew how could anyone know differently
somebody had to get in a ship and sail
across this unknown body of water to
find out what was on the other side
because you know it's not like anybody
out west what's going to get in a ship
and go that way the Aztecs and the
Mayans and the Incas they weren't
getting in ships and exploring anything
so Columbus had to be the guy he didn't
have satellites okay
Columbus navigated mostly with dead
reckoning through completely uncharted
waters he covered like 5,000 miles of
Uncharted ocean
with nothing but dead right you know
dead reckoning is that's like you you
you figure out your last fixed point so
the last port where you are at and and
you you you figure out based on
mathematical calculations and you come
up with kind of an estimate of where
you're headed but part of that
calculation you know what you need for
that calculation you need to know how
fast you're going well in 1492 how do
you figure out how fast your ship is
going again you don't have GPS so you
know what they had to do they called it
heaving the log okay this is how they
would for us we just check in a you know
the the speedometer but for them it was
heaving the log and so that literally
meant that they would take a piece of
wood and they would throw it into the
water and then just judge based on how
long it you know how long it takes for
the wood to drift away from them they
would from there that extrapolate their
speed and then they would factor that in
with the last fixed point and the other
calculations and then they would figure
out where they were going
so using that method across unknown
waters Columbus managed to make it to
the Caribbean and then make it back
there three more times you want to try
that okay start in Spain with nothing
but a compass and a piece of wood get
into a ship and make your way to Cuba
you think you can do it alive I think
that's quite an achievement you know and
you'd think that that a bunch of people
in modern society who can't even locate
their local supermarket two and a half
miles away without GPS you think we'd be
pretty impressed with Columbus like in
order for you if you wanted to to go ten
miles down the road on a highway you're
gonna be using your GPS which is
connected to a network of satellites in
space I mean you need a network of
satellites in space communicating with
your phone at the speed of light just to
make it you know fifty block
it's down the street so yeah I think we
should be pretty impressed with Columbus
and the other explorers and what about
the Indians that at that Columbus
encountered yeah some of them were
peaceful but we've taken this image of
the peaceful Indians to ridiculous
lengths I mean bear in mind there was a
tribe called the carrots and they rained
terror on the region where Columbus
landed these were brutal and violent
people who regularly feasted on human
beings this again is a concept utterly
foreign to European the idea of eating
other people and this was not uncommon
among Indian tribes now on his first
voyage Columbus never encountered any
Caribes but he heard about them and then
he encountered them on his second voyage
here's something they don't shoot they
don't teach you in school
Columbus actually tried to free actually
did free a number of Indian captives
that the Caribes were preparing to eat
so in one village on an island where
Columbus had stopped the Spaniards they
found a young boy tied up in a cage and
he was being fattened for consumption
and so when Columbus encountered stuff
like that he would oftentimes free the
people so you know Columbus he never
governed with the the savagery of an
Aztec King or or even a Carib chieftain
but he was a pretty bad governor in his
own right
and he did took take slaves he was a man
of his time in that way and he was a
pretty incompetent governor but we have
to keep in mind back in those days if
you were an explorer and a sea captain
you were expected to be I mean you had
to be a navigator captain an astronomer
a mathematician
and then when you made it to your
destination you also had to be a
politician and a governor and a king I
mean you had to be all of those things
and very few of those men could do all
of those things perfectly I don't think
any man in the world could so I think
all in all it should be said that
Columbus was brilliant on the sea not so
brilliant on land this kind of a common
dynamic Cortez was a great warrior when
he conquered the Aztecs he wasn't a very
good governor afterwards Magellan was an
incredible navigator who sailed the
circumference of the globe almost but he
got himself killed in an unnecessary
battle with a tribe in the Philippines
so you know he also had his flaws and a
Magellan you know Magellan's another guy
that we now look to and we judge for his
his ruthlessness but you think about
what he was up against he was looking
for a passage so he could sail all the
way around the globe in the 1500s again
without GPS without anything and along
the way he had to deal with you know
with hostile tribes that he encountered
he had to deal with starvation he had a
deal with disease he had to deal with
mutinies and so yeah he was a little bit
brutal in fact when he made it to South
America and they they decided to to kind
of camp out in a harbor over for winter
there was a mutiny took place and now I
mean just think about Magellan he's got
his he's got his ships he's on the other
side of the world he's in this unknown
wilderness he's thousands amount of
miles away from any kind of authority
and now he's got a mutiny on his hands
so what does he do he he brutally
squashes the mutiny and he takes one of
the mutineers as an example he has a mad
executed and he quarters him which means
he cuts off his limbs and he puts his
limbs on different parts of the ship as
a warning to the others not to not to
try that again
now we can look at that and we could say
oh well that's just that's just very bad
that's you see this is not a man that we
can look up to or admire well again let
me ask you how do you handle that you're
a thousand you're thousands of miles
away from any kind of help you're on
this expedition now you've got a mutiny
on your hands and all your men are
ganging up to take over the the ship and
kill you I mean what do you do how do
you handle that so I think ultimately
what we're left with with you know a lot
of our cultural heroes were left with
this legacy of flawed men who are also
responsible for some of the greatest
achievements in the history of mankind
and maybe you can look at them and say
well I could have done that better I
guarantee that you couldn't but you
could say that I know that I couldn't
done it any better but the real fact of
the matter is you wouldn't have even
tried
you would not have gotten into a ship
and said all right I'm gonna sail that
way across this body of water and I have
no idea what's on the other side of it
or if there even is anything on the
other side you wouldn't have even done
that that takes courage I mean that
takes boldness
that requires a visionary that requires
a truly great man to do something like
that and the only reason why we exist
today the only reason why our
civilization exists is that great men
took great risks and did great things
and yeah I think we ought to look up to
them and admire them and build statues
to them and tell our children about them
and honor them and I think it's a it's a
it's a huge mistake when we start
apologizing for and erasing our own
history and it's also just a disgraceful
way to treat these men who gave you
everything I mean the people that
complain about Columbus you aren't
you're just sitting back on your butt on
on the sofa you know eating a snack
watching TV living off the fat of the
land living off of this civilization
that wouldn't have existed without men
like Columbus oh you're just sitting
there yeah but you know what he did this
and that wrong so yeah you know what I
don't need that guy
there's a very good chance you know that
if the Europeans had never come to the
new world they would still be ripping
you'd still have the Aztecs ripping out
hearts and you'd still have the Incas
killing children as sacrifices to their
gods I mean there's a very good chance
that would still be happening if the
Europeans hadn't shown up alright it's
gonna move my globe there as you can see
both of them thanks for watching
everybody
for listening Godspeed